[Music]
listen here bob paramount is going to
come crashing down we need hits
you've read the godfather right
godfather sure who hasn't
we've been all over town no one wants to
make this movie so i need you to produce
it
get going
[Music]
i can't believe you told me you read it
you better be fast on the plane oh yeah
that's big
[Music]
the goat father is bringing us too many
problems you want me to take care of it
gangster movies are dead this is not
just some gangster film we need someone
who understands the times
[Music]
he's got a great vision
we have to put this in the picture scene
about gangsters arguing over sauce no
seeing about family arguing over sauce
[Music]
i got no cast
do you think the kino is actually a
possibility cut it
dope cheeto
he's a nutcase
can one thing go right with this picture
[Music]
you want to make a movie that's gonna
make my people look like animals and
that ain't gonna happen i respect what
you're saying and i think i have a
solution to our problem
[Music]
you're still going to try to make this
thing i got no choice
i took a chance on you but you stabbed
me in the back i won't judge you if you
need to walk away
this is what it's all about
the excitement
the thrill
that's movie magic baby
[Music]
[Music]
you